welcome to this video but vitro zijn
yeah this is a GM car but Carlos Garcia
Palermo okay hmm i only played them once
it's a well-known player and he has see
however quite quite a long-standing
account but it seems i only have played
in ones on video yeah let's see play we
did you want to play it a little bit a
little bit safer this time not them the
sameish again which always sees you try
to find compensation for your structural
problems here it is some very slow earth
am yeah right try to play sorry play for
a very small advantage if possible why
does got the bishop pair but black is
very well developed and sometimes can
get the bishop back with a move like 94
so the bishops are not that that's scary
we should be too maybe even just
completing development black can go
Bishop g4 that's an idea for a form
pawn to e4 is also possible efore 94
then 95 those kind of ideas I definitely
in the position but ok we can play all
kinds of things look da door whatever so
I'm just going to play it simple here
with castling i wonder if i should play
rook t1 probably not ok here i can take
Bishop takes rook c8 yeah winning a
tempo an important temple oh it's not
doing that sir ok well surprising is a
bit much but I expected I expected the
animals ok um I wonder if f3 yourself is
possible or made possible it is but
leading to anything ok let's speed up
not play a slow game yet again so Group
D one can also kick it back
all right f6 night f5 is a possibility
maybe regrouping already s got to check
well its got check on f3 okay so I
better not
yeah I know this looks like a very lame
move but I try to play for little things
the bishop in particular but maybe it's
not really leading to anything much
probably not only 97 as a move Bishop f6
also
hmm I don't write as it says I didn't
expect I thought this would would be
leading to some trouble 95 okay just um
saying that I'm winning upon
I mean a seven was also hanging but this
is really not a very important point
1.e4 is important and it's not so clear
where the rook is actually going yeah
like rookie seven-night f5 as a also an
issue but i can take right
so we got a double rook endgame with the
pawn I'm threatening rook a seven which
is really annoying fam yep has to do
this I no way I make it sticky seven can
still take care of course and i will
write I just ignore the whole business
so c4 right
now double rook endgame with two points
is usually too much especially with the
with white having such active pieces the
rooks are very active check
now yeah resigned it's pretty much
hopeless I I always have this weakness
on b6 on the tech for some reason that
does not know and this undertake I have
h5 to create a second weakness and it's
simply two pawns rook endgame with two
pawns where the two points don't have
anything special going against them is
normally winning I mean I'm an active
here don't have any passive pieces so it
is a pretty pretty straightforward win
this this around here is certainly oops
let me do it differently does this kind
of thing is certainty about equal I
didn't do anything special here I
thought you should do this I mean just
playing for maybe here and then claim
that this is equal probably with success
this should be equal ok did that which
I'm not saying is bad but he had a
simpler way to play definitely no yeah
92 also thought that here this is 93
move I don't know it looks active but
isn't this a bit of an annoying move now
it's are threatening this and night here
yeah the computer already gives me a
pretty big edge 93 years it's not good
and after this he really is struggling
he's losing a pawn now and hereafter
ninety six assists since basically the
game will be very difficult to to keep
things going on night takes also strong
actually but it is a very good route
game game ok give he gives me a second
formant it's very good because I have a
completely sound structure the rooks are
active and yeah it is very good very
very close to 22 decisive edge
okay thanks for watching